we out here hello everyone
[Music]
we're live we're live
and always on time never on schedule but
always on time
never on schedule but always on time
whoa i'm rapping a little fast this
beat's super slow but i gotta take it
low
what's goodie what's goodie hot bread
the verse
my her my her
for those of you that join early
you get to hear me bust some bars my hip
hop name
in addition to why boy joe
and that dude
i'm a hip hoppity
hipster
with the flows call me joe okay
got bars they call me joel bars
[Music]
we
going far
thanks to you watching from afar
get it internet
let's get going ooh now we flowing this
be getting kind of going showing all the
folks that this white boy nopes
nopes
i don't know what i am sure of is this
is the live q a show
all right
what's goodie everyone what's good
what is goodie welcome to our weekly q a
here
that's a fun start for people who have
never joined one of these before and
they're like
i'd like to see what's going on on these
live streams they're doing three times a
week
and then they get here and it's just
michael sarah trying to rap
like wait wait did
ellen fell off
i guess this is fix it felix on his day
off
[Music]
but hello everyone how exciting to see
you i'm just getting everything pulled
up here
but this
my friends
is our weekly q a every single
wednesday we jump in here and
i answer your comedy questions we have a
good old pow-wow of a comedy time
so i am super jazzercised about this
so i hope y'all are having a good day
out there oh my gosh i'm not seeing any
comments
i hope that's
not a glitch
okay cool no one has commented yet i
just want to make sure i was like oh no
is it not working
or did i just start late
oh no is it not working or did i just
start late and people are still trying
to people are still finding
where the show is
oh vodka
so happy wednesday everyone
we are out here
all right gary
first comment gary
thank you friend
we appreciate you
you having a good day there gary
it's been good here i've been working on
i'm doing a a hot breath
like tour
this upcoming weekend and i want to meet
as many hop breathers as possible so i'm
going
i'm into the trip in maryland
headlining a show
in maryland of
hop breath or sandy bernstein
i'm headlining her show on may 2nd so on
saturday
april 30th i'm going up
to uh greensboro
for my buddy tyler chronicles show he's
actually
og friend he's been on the podcast twice
he actually opened up for me at my
comedy special
which is
um available now at joelbyerscomedy.com
if you would like to support your boy
here
um
see i'm going to
to his show but then on the way up i was
thinking about
stopping somewhere on the way up
um and i'm thinking on the way back for
maryland i'm going to stop at charlotte
i know
because that's kind of a little that's
like a good halfway point i'm gonna have
like a 10 hour drive that tuesday
but yeah i'm just trying to be as many
hop brothers as possible so i'm going to
be going up through north carolina
and uh virginia i'm in richmond sunday
so if anyone
i'm not pretty versus out you
or you know of someone in those areas
feel free to tag them here let them know
you know
oh what's goodie tavis good to see you
my friend tavis is out yet yo
appreciate you tavis
yeah so i've been prepping for that trip
there's a lot of logistics and stuff
that just
gets silly gooser when you get into it
you know
oh yeah
yeah i really want to
start getting out there and meeting
y'all and hanging out and doing shows
together and such so you can book me put
me on a show hmm
that's what sandy did i'm going up to
maryland
do her show so
let him know
but yeah welcome this is the q a
i wonder if i can one second
[Music]
maybe something like that something a
little fancy like that maybe just to let
people know it's
q and a day
awesome
all right i like that i like that right
there
now the folks know
[Music]
awesome all right thank you so much
tavis i appreciate you too man
you keep showing up you keep putting in
these reps man
it's always great to see on here
hey
what do y'all think of the music in the
background i feel like i asked that
every time
um
tavistas how many shows a week do you
try to do during a non-coveted lockdown
type period
well
it's different now
than it was early in my career early in
my career probably the first
i mean probably the first
nine ten years
yeah
i lived on stage
literally like
and if i didn't do a show i was at a
show like on the weekends if i wasn't
booked i would go watch a headliner and
study them and talk to them afterwards
so
now
it's a little bit different but back
then i was up at least once a night at
least once a night
for years and years and years and that's
why the number one piece of advice on
the podcast has been
get on stage that's literally the number
one piece of advice i've ever gotten
it's the most universal piece of advice
i've gotten over 400 comedy interviews
so i just took that advice
that i heard early on
been hearing that my whole career i was
like well i just better live on stage so
i mean it was literally
at least one a night seriously
and most most of the time more
uh but now it's like a balance thing
with like because you have a life
and a lot of you have families and such
so there's a balance to be made there so
like for example
i'm about to be gone
for several days so i'm home all this
week like i'm not going out anywhere
like after this i'm with family
like i am i am in family mode this week
because i know i'm gonna be gone
for the next few days so
that's the balance of it but if i'm not
gone on the weekends i'll usually go out
and do a few shows tuesdays i can
usually get in three shows can just
bounce from one show to the next
and then
uh wednesdays there's a few shows around
so i mean
i'll get up
maybe four
four times a week
on average maybe now but early on every
every night
you gotta think where i am i'm like
like over 12 years into it i'm not
saying i don't need to get reps and
stuff i still do
but i'm just saying when you start
getting on the road a lot more
and you're doing more headlining sets
and you're getting on the road you know
there's kind of a balance of you know
well if you're going on the weekends
you're gone during the week where's life
where's family you know so
that's what it is so that's about where
it is what about you tavis how often are
you getting up i'd be curious to know
all y'all watching how how long um how
often are you all getting up if you have
been up yet if you haven't been up yet
also say that
um
nermal asked how did your show goes
which show
the show i had
last week
went great
yeah yeah if it was if it's the show
that i talked about last week it went
awesome so much fun we're going to do
another one they were already talking
about doing another one
and had new ideas for marketing and
stuff and that i'm telling you
if you want to start your own show
and
you want to get stage time
which is the best way to start your own
show because i do tell people a lot of
times oh you got to start your own show
and it can sound easier than it is i
mean you've got to find the right venue
then you've got to like book the show
and you've got to promote the show and
lug equipment around if they don't have
it you know so
it's really
starting your own show is really about
the relationship with the venue so you
want to make sure you're working with a
venue that is willing to work with you
not someone who's thinking that you're
just going to come in
and do all the work but it's like a
collaborative effort so like this show i
did last wednesday
they were all on board they helped they
helped create marketing materials they
helped market it they were very
proactive in marketing it not only in
store but also online their email list
like
they're coming up with ideas you know
because i've done shows i've produced a
lot of shows where
this is kind of like the venue
just kind of
like isn't as proactive they're just
like oh we have this thing
take it or leave it you know it's not
it's not a collaborative effort and i've
interviewed the top comedy bookers in
the country as well and in the industry
and that's the number one thing they say
as well is that it starts with a good
relationship with the venue so you so
take time don't get impatient you may
say i want to start my own show and not
find a venue until
six months later honestly but once you
start looking for it you'll find it but
make sure it's
like people you jive with
tavis at
five mike's like five times a week on
average recently i was on some proper
shows though
nice but that's like two a month for now
very nice
keep grinding fam keep grinding
i love it i love it
that was a pretty good rant about
finding the right venue too wasn't it
i actually
was like
a legit have a show production
master class
um
here i'm just going to
uh pin that to the top for anyone
interested in the class or workshops
that we have available to help you level
up
because i actually have a show
production master class where i go into
more detail not only about how to book
the right show and find the right venue
and set it up but also market it and all
those fun things
that you hear how do you start your own
show or you hear oh yeah i'll just start
my own show i'll just walk in somewhere
and it happens no not the case not the
case
so i've been doing comedy over 12 years
i've produced
several shows i produced one in atlanta
for eight years in a row and it won best
of atlanta
one year and now i'm producing several
shows around the atlanta area so i've
seen the good the bad and the bombing of
what to look for and what to avoid when
producing a show so
any of the
workshops or
classes we have
are all based on things
that took me years to learn and years to
discover which was just trial and error
and just banging my head against the
wall and just not getting anywhere
to work through that to actually start
to learn these lessons that hopefully
now you just have instant access to so
you can just focus on getting funny
and getting paid too by the way
all right
um
so i see in the facebook group
gary
do y'all like this music by the way are
y'all feeling the music is it
distracting
um
gary said getting gigs how to
my venues have gone out of business from
covet economy
gosh i'm sorry to hear that gary i hope
you're doing all right i know it hit it
hit everyone you know
it was tough
um
yeah i mean getting gigs i mean this
community is a great place to start
honestly like whatever area you're in
yeah like gary uh gary bachman said he
said
he mentioned going to like an open mic
where there's musicians poets and comics
is it worth doing i think so yeah i used
to do
poetry open mics here in atlanta i did
uh music open mics i did karaoke night
my friend and i
went to a karaoke night and we're like
hey can we instead of doing a song do
comedy and then we're like yeah
you know
but uh getting gigs gary yeah i mean
this commute is a great place to start
where are you looking to
you know start doing gigs like you want
to get out on the road maybe post in the
facebook group
uh where you're at where you're looking
to get gigs and connect you know because
i can tell you
80 90 of the shows i get are from other
comedians they're from
the network
so
use it to your advantage you know and
see what sticks but locally if you could
start producing your own show that's
something we've been talking about on
here a good bit
that's another good option
but
it's tough you know if you're saying
businesses are gone from covet economy i
think
i was i was um
i'm planning to come through charlotte
on the way back
from maryland on um may 3rd and i was
gonna stop doing like no maybe there's
shows or whatnot but i mean i think
i saw a post in their facebook group
there's only like one
show up go up open mic right now
um so i mean yeah the covet has really
hit a lot of people
um
so if you can't produce your own
you know
look for areas outside of your own city
to hopefully get gigs
dragon4
said should you test out new stuff at
main show or save it for open mic oh
yeah i would say save it for open mic
for sure um i mean if you're on if
you're on like a main show and i'm
assuming by main show you mean like a
page show
um
[Music]
but yeah if you're like on a showcase or
a main show or paid show i mean you're
there
to do the job of comedy essentially
let me let me scroll down and see if
they
but i mean
i won't say to keep that exclusively
i'll just say don't treat the main show
like an open mic like you know prepare
yourself you know rehearse have a set
list
know what you want to open with know
what you want to close with like know
where you want to go don't just go up
and guess like you're doing an open mic
so if you are going to do
a new joke at a main show
then be sure
that you have rehearsed that joke you
know where that joke is going and that
joke is couched between
jokes you know work so you hit him with
one that works try a new one regardless
of it just go to one you know works so
if the new one misses it bounces back
if the new one hits it bounces up the
next joke
oh nice that's so cool yeah gary up in
jamestown new york home of the national
comedy center yeah i saw my buddy steve
rogers recording an album up there that
was very cool which is about to come out
i believe it's up for pre-order now
fun fact as well
i have new koozies
it says live laugh chug just in time for
spring and summer season
and uh
they're for sale right now holla at your
boy if you want one
live laugh love but it's live life chug
all right
um
good now i'll belch into the microphone
uh let me see
have you ever had another comedian take
your spotted open mic when you had your
name called
that happened to me what's the best tip
on getting better at writing and what's
the best book on writing
whoa there's a lot of questions there
um
whoever had another comedian we'll start
with the first one
take my spot and open mic
um
no but i have done that to another
comedian
um
because they weren't there so there have
been moments early in my career
when i was still like scrapping for
stage time
that
they called a comedian and the comedian
wasn't there they gave the communion
ample time to show up
uh and then i just ran up there and it's
just so unexpected and they're just like
all right that's that's fine too since
they were already expecting someone to
go up
so i have done that
but i've never had one like take my spot
um
if i'm being better at writing i mean
writing is a muscle
the more you use it the stronger it gets
you know it's just a lot a lot a lot of
repetition and understanding that it's
probably one out of every 20 things you
write you're going to end up keeping
and that's just the math of comedy you
know and some people want to argue with
that and be like no that's that's being
dramatic it's the ratio's much you know
one out of three things i write are good
and i was like okay well there's someone
who's
comedy probably gets a one out of three
stars as well but
um yeah just keep writing you know
if you're looking for books you know or
workshops i have workshops linked in the
live chat of this you can just go to
hotbreathmedia.com
uh if you're really looking to level up
like your joke writing i have a workshop
called five steps to funny
where it's literally five steps to take
an idea
and turn it into a punch line so
that's there for you that can definitely
help you get better at writing i also
have a comedy writing master class over
there but the best book on writing i
mean there's really
there's several out there
and it really comes down to like
personal preference honestly like i'll
tell you the book
and
it's great you're asking this because
i am literally on our podcast right now
going through
[Music]
uh our comedy author series
which is literally
we've interviewed basically every
well-known comedy author in the industry
uh greg dean judy carter
jerry corley stephen rosenfield john
voorhaus
scott dickers i mean literally
every single well-known comedy author
we've interviewed
so and that's all going on in the
podcast right now series so definitely
check that out but i'm gonna put a link
here
to um i actually have a link to all my
favorite comedy writing books that i
just put in
there it'll take you to amazon and
there's a list of them there
but i start with greg dean's
step-by-step to stand up
um
but yeah there's plenty there
joe said i'm rachey comedian how do you
get better at riding clean and would you
recommend doing another advanced comedy
class at comedy castle i did beginner
class with bill
burchard
um
cool uh i'm not familiar
with um
it depends on how much you're like
i don't know i mean whether or not you
want to take another class is really up
to you joe but if you
if you think the class is
listen stand up comedy is getting on
stage
and if you think this
class is going to
help you get on stage more
and afterwards continue to do it
then go for it you know but this is what
i tell people when they ask me about my
classes and workshops because i'm not i
mean i'm a comedian you know i'm not
like i'm not a career
like
teacher i guess i love helping people
and everything i
talk about are things that i have
personal and professional experience
with
so i i never like trying to be like this
class is the it's the like you know
the silver bullet to all your comedy
problems listen
everything
that i have
out there you know the podcast in this
channel like you know everything i'm
putting out
is to give the highest quality
education and tips for comedians as
possible
but i say that also
if you think joining a class or workshop
is going to get on stage for you
it won't
so
by all means
join it to learn the craft of comedy
writing and how you can develop and
level up faster it's going to save you
years on the learning curve
but what you learn
you have to take on stage or what you
learn you have to put on the page if
you're taking these classes and
workshops to develop like a tv writing
or you know learning how to just write
funnier
you got to put it on the page just like
taking it to the stage you know so
really
just ask yourself that if you're wanting
to take this advanced class that you're
talking about in your local town
we'll just make sure you give a lot of
thought to why
and what you will get out of it
and go from there but you've gotta yeah
you've gotta get on stage that's
that's where it all happens my friend
great question though
[Music]
um how do you get better at writing
clean i mean writing clean
a lot of it is word choice you know you
can still have the same subject matter
but just not speak as graphically about
it you can be more clever about it
a lot of word choice you can just if you
have a dirty joke
you can just
write it out as it is word for word
and then write down what is the premise
what am i trying to say with this joke
what is this joke in a single like
phrase
what is it about what is the message i'm
trying to convey
and then look to reword and rework the
joke to still express that premise
without all the dirtiness and it could
be a dirty premise but you can use
innuendo and things like that instead of
just being right on the nose
yo
i'm going to take a sip because this q a
is getting lit i'm telling you that
right meow
we're spitting a lot of sauce today
hey hey hey
all right
what's goodie fam
do you think sometimes comedians should
dial it down just for the sake of what's
coming
i recently had a very good joke get a
very under average laugh due to this
fact
do you think camia should dial it down
what do you mean what do you mean by
that buddy
not exactly sure what you mean by that
i'm not sure what you're saying dial
down
um
yeah please please elaborate on that my
friend
dragon 4 is three hours too much to ride
a day no i don't think so
when i interviewed ted alexandro he said
you'll never regret
uh working harder or it was like you'll
never regret writing more essentially
and one of my favorite christopher titus
quotes who hasn't been on the show yet
but will
was like i hate writing but love having
written
so it's how you feel after is really
where a lot of the motivation comes
so no three hours go for it my friend
now i do want to
clarify what writing
is
because i think a lot of people just
assume
writing is oh i sit down and i crank out
a bunch of new ideas and then i've
written for the day
writing is literally
it could be listening back to an old set
that's writing writing could literally
be
editing old jokes you know writing can
be reading through your old notebooks to
look for new joke ideas with like fresh
eyes like
all that is considered
writing it's not all
just
breaking out new ideas over and over
again you know there's something to
refining and just reviewing and just
saturating your brain
with your comedy writing it whether it's
listening or reading it or writing it it
all is a productive use of your time and
helps you develop i recommend doing all
aspects of that
that's just something a lot of people
don't
think about writing is reciting it as
well when we interviewed mark normand
that's how he writes he said he walks
around like a crazy person in his hotel
room talking to himself for like an hour
and huh he seems to be doing pretty good
uh ramy oh rami
tunisia what's poppin tunisia
we need like a hot breath map of like
where everyone is in the world seriously
um
hey guys i live in tunisia and there are
no open mics around i try to write jokes
every day as there's something else i
can do to improve my comedy career
before getting to a country where i can
get on stage
there are zoom shows
i think that's a great place to start
you know there are zoom shows that you
can perform on
and just get reps that way and meet
other comedy people you know that may be
your best bet right now
uh and shimon like like on a graph where
they're
an average joke when you get the giggles
giggles
in and another
that is the high point of a show i did a
story
oh
um well you are you want to end your
bits on the biggest laugh and that's a
challenge with developing a bit that
like builds and crescendos
is it's got to end with the loudest
laugh you can't have like the loudest
laugh in the middle and then it comes
back down and starts to build up again
you you you the challenge is okay how do
i end on this biggest laugh or okay i
have this big laugh how do i create an
even bigger laugh on the other side of
it
so yeah what you're saying there yeah
the
the rule of thumb in the challenge is
that
uh
you gotta get that big laugh at the end
so it's editing out
what's after it or it's
um
adding more before it so you end on that
big laugh
hey
good question though
[Music]
oh we vibing now
what did gary say in the facebook group
i like to choose my audience biker jokes
for biker crowd family jokes for family
one set fits all audience is a tough act
true
yep you can always you can find your
audience and whatnot i've always been
under the mindset that i want my jokes
to work everywhere
but that's
literal personal preference that's why i
mean i don't tell anyone
oh they should be clean or shouldn't be
clean i don't you do whatever you want i
don't tell people what they should and
shouldn't do i just know my personal
preference whatever your personal
preference is follow that
it's a sense of humor i i really do
believe it's like a sixth sense that we
have where it is like a sense of humor
so tap into that listen to that
mine just happens to be i i want to do
jokes for everyone you know grandkids
the grandparents and when i started in
atlanta
i did shows with all white people with
all black people with all hipsters with
all
uh like
uh country club people literally
everywhere
and if a joke worked and let's say in
all white room but didn't work in all
black room i would just get rid of the
joke so i always wanted my material
to be a little more um universal
but that's literal personal preference
something i will say about being a clean
comedian though or at least
having the ability at least having the
clean set
because there's just more work
there's just more work if you can be
clean i just booked a gig performing at
an avenue
like a shopping place
for you know a comfortable like liz in
this comedy game there's not a lot of
money sorry it's either like zero or a
hundred bajillions you know there's no
real middle much of a middle class in
comedy
but yeah
i've gotten paid perform at the avenue
performed at company potlucks birthday
parties i've done like corporate
team building events i mean if you can
be clean
you can get booked more and that being
said i know tons of dirty comics making
a killer career so
it's your personal preference it's
really what you want
what you want there fam
so you do you boo you do you
hey
cool beans
well are there any other questions any
other questions any other any other any
other questions
and no pressure either fam i'm just
trying to
we come in here on wednesdays
hang out with each other
i've just been planning this trip which
is
trying to do it the right way you know
want to make the most of the trip meet
as many people as possible so it's fun
it'll be worth it i'm excited to go to
richmond
my roommate from college is a news
anchor in richmond
so we're gonna go meet up and i'm doing
a couple shows there too
ah that's good vodka there
oh yeah
i missed the question joe
oh i'm also doing
comedy on joke zoom
you talk with other comedians about one
joke with other comedians and how to
make spotify playlists for stand-up i
don't know how to do it
oh yeah i don't know
oh wow
there are more jokes they weren't
appearing over here
my bad
fams um i honestly don't know how to
make a spotify comedy playlist
i honestly don't i don't really use
spotify
uh i'm sure i'm sure i should i know a
lot of people are on there and whatnot
but i honestly don't really use it so
i'm not really sure i literally use
youtube for like everything
literally
so
that that's kind of my life you can
literally get anything on youtube and if
i splurged and got the youtube premium
so there aren't ads and you get free
youtube music as well
uh yeah it
it's worth the price not sitting through
all those ads for sure so i really just
use youtube so i'm not sure buddy
um
do you think tick tock is a good place
to upload stand up yeah it seems to be
working for people
you know it's a it's a volume game i
mean it seems people are just putting
out anything and everything out there
and like doing these crowd work clips
and such so
yeah i think you can definitely get a
following i've seen several people
and you know funny you say that
i just posted
on um
on the youtube channel just yesterday i
did a live q a or monday i did it with
my buddy ben palmer
who is
gosh almost three million followers on
tick tock now he's selling out he was
just in atlanta and we got to link up
and reminisce on the old times of us
doing the hood rooms together and him
getting slapped on stage and such so
that's on the youtube channel right now
but yeah i would say he would certainly
say tick tock is a great place to post
your comedy yeah
but and it's it's a different game out
there for y'all i mean you knew her
comics
man i feel sorry for
i mean i gotta do it too but you all
have to like learn comedy
get on stage figure out how to navigate
a comedy scene and record everything and
post production everything
like
all for free
so yeah
it's a grind out there it's that's the
new hustle though
well normal i mean you address it right
up front you know
open with a joke about your hand and
that'll help kind of ease any tension
and it'll help you get more confident
when you hear the audience laugh you're
gonna start getting more confident
quicker
and then you'll just
bowl it from there bowl it get it
yeah just open up with a joke about it
you know
get personal
this has this is not the same thing at
all really but i used to have a mustache
and i would open up with jokes about it
because that's the first thing that
people noticed
um
i divided this one story into two parts
and sandwiched a bit with the same them
inside
what that did was give me two of my
funniest bits together and the climaxes
kind of collide under two minutes
so
that does for me
is the second laugh
the one
that is the show designed seemed to be
undervalued
hmm
i'm having trouble following it
i'm sorry buddy
um
do you want to come on the show and talk
me through it
oh
what
yes i'm having trouble just following
exactly what like the joke and what
happened it seems like
what i'm assuming you're saying is that
the joke
before the ending joke was
funnier
a hank
it's kind of late here
no worries buddy that's hilarious
no worries at all my friend where are
you i'm sorry i yeah i'm just trying to
oops let me stop this
parts in a sandwich and sandwiched a bit
with the same them inside
that did was give me two of my funniest
bits together
india awesome
yeah we have a lot of comedians in india
that rock with us we appreciate that we
appreciate all the
all the hot breath of earth out there
but yes i'm not sure my friend
so what that does for me is the second
laugh the one that
is the show designed
for seems undervalued
well honestly
based on what you're saying it only
seems undervalued to you i mean it seems
like the audience is laughing at both
one just louder than the other but that
i mean that's not a bad thing you know
seems like they're both getting laughs
though is what it's sounding like
so it sounds like you goody fam
what's goodie what's goodie
both of those are water by the way
i didn't want y'all to think i was
chasing anything
i ain't chasing nothing but lacroix with
my brand new live laugh chug koozie
so yeah that's a great question though
i hope that helps you there
all the way from india i hope that helps
you
what's goody bo johnson
what's poppin fam doing the weekly
wednesday q a here
so if anyone has any questions feel free
to pop em in the live chat cause we
chilling for the next little bit
how do you get on comedy central
slash bigger platform do you have to
have a big following
yeah
essentially at this point
and the name of the game is that you're
the comedy central the name of the game
is that
you're creating the bigger platform that
creates the audience that then creates
the leverage
to
do business with these bigger entities
but it does all start with you yep
building your following
yeah i mean there are
managers and agents and things like that
but i i think with the internet and then
how everything got accelerated during
covid
i mean i think that's
that's more
evident than ever that's the name of the
game
your following
build it and they will come you know
that's how my friend ben palmer trolls
got a following on social media now he's
selling out
venues around the country you know so
it's the name of the game i literally
just interviewed
um a
uh booker club owner
from
um
from atlanta who started uptown actually
when you hear me talking about
earthquakes comedy special time because
it's amazing but um he talks about
owning a club with another guy in
atlanta
it was actually gary who
owned the club with him and gary's
become one of the most well known in the
industry
but basically i interviewed him recently
which hasn't been released yet oh i
could release that on the patreon
for all you patreonians out there would
you like to hear that before everyone
else
long story short
he basically
said
his advice to young comedians today
would be build a following on social
media and then build a stand-up career
that was his i mean his basically is
looking at from the business side of
well the name of the game is butts and
seats so whoever gets butts and seats
however they do
that's who we want to book at the club
it's a business
so
every club owner is different every
booker's different but when it gets down
to like the bottom line of people
or people in the building or gnaw
spending money
social media has a lot of leverage
oh bo said i'm beyond excited for the
upcoming shows in baltimore hot breath
is taking over maryland yo and nick
baskerville
is actually gonna be there fam and he
just asked the question nick is on the
show this is so lit this is gonna be so
much fun i'm super excited about it as
well bo
[Music]
nick asked
what does it take to be ready to pitch
dry bar
i mean
i got referred
so
i got referred from very credible
sources
and it was a pretty smooth process i'll
say but i will say that saying
i've been doing comedy over 12 years
i've interviewed over 400 comedians i've
been working hard
at the craft of comedy and also just
networking and building friends along
the way that then ended up helping me
get this opportunity
so
i think it
it takes you being
ready for it like professionally it's
like and there's some people
it's like take the opportunity of course
it was probably one of the most positive
experiences i've ever had in comedy
everyone there was beyond helpful beyond
accommodating it really made they really
care about comedy there and it made you
feel like royalty there
but you want to make sure you know if
you get on drivebar
you want to make sure you have something
to back it up like you want to have a
library
of content
you want to have a resume you want to to
have a whole world for people to fall
into you know you don't want to jump on
dry bar early it goes viral and then
people try to find you and you don't
even have like a website or something
where they could book you and things
like that you know so there are a few
professional things you want in place in
terms of yeah like
having your affairs in order on social
media and such so when people discover
you on dry bar
when they google you
they're gonna see a whole lot more and
become fans
uh but that's really it you know just
being ready that way and then just being
funny i mean i think we did 30-minute
sets
um
and based what i did for my 30 minutes
the majority of it
i whittled down my comedy special that i
self-produced
because since then you know i was on the
road and i was
repping those jokes and headlining sets
so they got better and tighter and
refined so my dry bar is like my first
comedy special on steroids i just
condensed it all down made it super
tight and strong
so i was ready for it and if something
happens you know opportunities appear
afterwards i'm ready for them uh and
that took me 12 years
to get to this point you know so some
people do it in two years you know
everyone's different but that's
my personal journey into it
oh cool yeah and to pitch yeah i think i
got referred and then i think i sent a
link and things like that
uh put up shut up and stand up said do
you think will smith should tate amber
heard
yo real talk fam i don't keep up with
news or anything i know about the will
smith slap situation
and i've heard
about the amber heard stuff but i
literally
don't watch the news at all although my
wife really most the time just tells me
what i need to know like i really don't
keep up with any of that so i can't tell
you anything
going on with that beyond uh she pooped
the bed and
johnny depp was drunk on wine
so
i don't know who to believe in any of
that
a john
mondragon asked do you think you should
open by telling the crowd how many times
you have performed if you're very new no
nah i get into it get into it john
nope
jump right into it my friend
you deserve to be there don't discount
or try to limp into your set
by saying guys i've only been up like
five times so go easy on me nah go in
there and give it to him john for sure
you got this buddy you got this
oh wait
i did the wrong sound effect
oh no
[Music]
that's the super chat horn
there it is you got this john
um
your wife is your cliff notes to the
news hilarious very true
it's all very true
kyle asked
is it worth performing song parodies
of old songs as long as they're funny
i've heard people say you want your
material to be timely and other people
say it just has to be funny
yep that's that's a real personal
preference there kyle to be completely
honest um
it's is it worth it to you like you're
the one performing them
if you enjoy doing them and people enjoy
hearing them i don't see why not
but it's kind of a personal preference
on doing what you want to do there
so yes you hear what other people say
but what do you say kyle what does your
instinct say like we referenced earlier
in this your sense of humor that sixth
sense
what is that what is that telling you
and run with that
and if you're not sure try it and see
how it feels and go from there
what do you think kyle what do you think
you're gonna do there though i'd be
instead of here
let's see
um
uh bo outside of l.a new york do you
feel
do you feel they're ideal cities to
further build a comedy career if so
which ones i think atlanta
i think atlanta is a dope place to
develop as a comedian there are shows
every single night of the week and i was
just in la and i can tell you
for real for real
atl's got la comedy unlocked
way way way funnier dude
and there's way more stage time and
there they're way higher quality of
shows as well so it's a dope comedy
scene atlanta
nashville
i haven't i i'm gonna say these
anecdotally i don't know i've heard of
chicago
i've heard denver
i heard austin i have been to houston
houston has a dope comedy scene
um
yeah i haven't been to a lot of them but
that's why i'm hitting the road you know
so i'm starting to see them
but yeah there's a handful of them there
oh nice and kyle said i think i'll keep
the song parodies of old songs once i'm
done revising them but i'll still try
parody news songs to write original
comedy songs whenever i can yeah yeah
that's a good system there kyle yeah
yeah
oh yeah it's always self-deprecating
comedy jokes yeah i see that there on
shimon
yep
it's true
it's always a good opening there hey
guys well not always but i mean
it's an opener get the ball rolling
you do that when there's
audience and low numbers yeah it's
always good
um
hell yeah comedy baby
i love that's everywhere though
i love just
the unifying
life of being a comedian is like
somewhere
in some comedy scene
in the world there's a comedian roasting
a small audience
oh rami said i never thought of that
thank you so much good yeah yeah happy
to help there rami
yeah denver i'd love to get out to
denver
i will i'm definitely gonna start
hitting the road more
um oh austin op hi i'm a stand-up queen
for like one and a half years well
welcome to the hot breath verse fam
welcome aboard those of you watching
right now make sure you are subscribed
to our youtube channel as well
don't get it twisted fam
we are almost at 20 000 subscribers
which is dope af to death
it also appears we are
starting to come
to the end
of
our
live q a today
a live q a today
[Music]
yeah but i'm about to sneeze for sure
no i totally agree on shimon um
i don't like
i don't like roasting audiences and
things like that i think it's demeaning
and the audience that is there came to
laugh they didn't come to ruin your
shows so you really want to
nurture and uplift those people not
roast them
but
young comics do that they make that
mistake you know i've been guilty of
that but yeah anytime it's like a small
show like that one the booker doesn't
appreciate it the venue doesn't
appreciate it and the audience doesn't
appreciate it
so it's really
a waste of time and only hurts your show
really like it can be a crutch as well
it's way more
way more gratifying to actually
get a small audience over on your side
be like oh man i can do this i can
entertain two people or two thousand
people
noise
my wife was texting me
oh and the music hit
oh yeah that would be cool austin yeah
yeah but i do the live on youtube every
uh i do this every wednesday but yeah
more ig live would be nice
found your channel to trying to get
better crowd work with andrew schultz
any advice
yeah crowd work is one of those skills
you really have to
do to develop and get better at but
a good starting out way to do crowd work
is to do crowd work about topics that
set up material you have so if you have
material about marriage
do crowd work with people talking about
marriage so when that crowd works starts
to like lose some steam you can go into
your marriage material that's a good way
to get into crowd work just kind of
using it as a way to transition then
into your material
dragon been doing comedy eight months 19
for i'm 19 nice
yeah
well man this has been a dope q a i'm
seeing a lot of new faces in here which
is always so cool
all around the world
so i appreciate y'all hanging out and
all the love and support you do i do
these q as every single
wednesday
at 5 p.m eastern time every wednesday at
10 a.m eastern time i also do a live
joke writing competition
every tuesday at 5 p.m i do a hot breath
live like comedy news and joke feedback
show
so we doing a lot out here
but
i appreciate you all so much for hanging
out with me today i
i'm gonna go do some
fun
uh
family time now before i hit the road
this weekend so thank you all so much
for hanging out and asking such great
questions
go tell your comedian friends about us
and we'll see on the other side
you